vous
[Musique]
le trafic a repris aux chômeurs oxame à
la frontière canado américaine
en quelques années c'est devenu un des
principaux points d'entrée de demandeurs
d'asile au pays après la pause
pandémique c'est une reprise qui a des
répercussions dans les écoles du grand
montréal l'année scolaire 2019-2020
c'était vraiment une année record pour
nous le haut niveau de l'accueil des
demandeurs d'asile depuis la réouverture
du chemin ensemble on a l'impression de
reprendre là où on avait laissé ce futur
quel jour quel mois l'accueil des
enfants immigrants allophones pour
l'année scolaire en cours a lieu jusqu
en juin
depuis janvier le centre de service
scolaire de montréal a inscrit sept cent
cinquante nouveaux élèves de quoi
remplir une grande école primaire les
élèves arrivés comme immigrants avec
leurs parents comme un leader mais aussi
un grand nombre de réfugiés plus
vulnérables où dès qu'il ya une reprise
au chemin oxame on le sent quelques
jours voire quelques semaines plus tard
donc présente ma long sur les 210 enfin
qu'on a reçu au mois de mars le tiers de
ces enfants ne venaient de quatre pays
dont qui était le mexique haïti la
colombie et le brésil
en montérégie les inscriptions sont à la
hausse ou si on a plus de demandeurs
d'asile qui reviennent avec la pandémie
ce sont des élèves qui nous arrive
doublement vulnérabiliser de par le fait
qu'ils n'ont pas été scolarisés souvent
pendant plusieurs mois parce qu'ils ont
pas eu le temps de préparer leur
parcours migratoire et empoche
choisissent souvent le pays
l'enseignante isabelle bijou est aux
premières loges dans sa classe d'accueil
du centre de service scolaire de la
pointe-de-l'île elle vient de prendre
une adolescente ukrainienne sous son
aile moi c'est ma 13ème année on a eu
les élèves tremblement de terre en haïti
sont un des arguments on a eu des
syriens on a eu des élèves aussi qu'ils
ont passés par le chômeur oxame qui ont
traversé l'amérique à pied qui sont
partis du brésil on a des élèves qui ont
perdu des membres de leur famille on
chemine donc on a quand même de
l'expérience avec des élèves qui ont
vécu tout autrement les élèves peuvent
passer un an ou deux en classe d'accueil
avant d'aller dans une classe régulière
la classe d'accueil pour super bien son
nom le parce que c'est vraiment un
endroit pour accueillir les élèves un
endroit de de transition un endroit
chaleureux pour que les pour dire
bienvenue chez vous finalement on a de
quoi être fier là dessus c'est que on
aide chaque année des milliers d'élèves
à apprendre le français pour nos élèves
qui arrivent aux primaires c'est
fascinant à quel point ils apprennent
rapidement neo mais c'est un système qui
fait face aussi aux mêmes défis que
l'ensemble du réseau scolaire une rareté
de main-d'oeuvre ça prend des classes
mais ça prend aussi des enseignants
j'ai peur qu'on ait perdu beaucoup d
expertise à cause de pandémie la
fermeture des frontières il ya plein de
profs qui se sont retrouvés dans des
classes ordinaires j'espère que ce
profond en revenir on se prépare
maintenant à accueillir les élèves
l'ukrainien ici anne louise despatie
radio canada montréal